at this stage we're talking about
Assyrian who has a status of refugee in
Sweden for the past 10 years he asked
asylum in France but he already has in
fact two ages of refugee so he's a
Syrian he has a refugee status which was
given to him in Sweden 10 years ago of
course we uh made contact with all the
judicial services and the intelligence
services from other countries in Europe
elsewhere and he has no judicial
antecedents then there's no Intelligence
on him and no psychiatric information on
him today it should be a day of unity
solidarity solidarity as far as he's
very little children their parents their
families and all the inhabitants of ANSI
who of course very shocked by what's
happened